good morning Hank it's Wednesday August
31st apparently it's talked to people
other than your brother week my shirt
matches the boxes behind me I'm gonna
change yeah I think that's better
although I wonder if we can take it down
a button No
so like I want to address the people who
have recently ended or will soon and
their formal education and enter what is
known as the real world ok the first
thing you'll notice upon entering the
real world is that it is neither more or
less real than any of the previous
worlds you have encountered but you'll
likely notice that the real world does
have this interesting mix of like
crushing monotony and paralyzing terror
it's not a real world it's more of a sea
mapped world like there's the crushing
monotony of waking up at the same time
sitting in the same traffic going to the
same job and then coming home to pay the
same bills with your only distractions
being like television and video games
and YouTube but there's also the
constant paralyzing terror of knowing
that if you somehow screw up sitting in
traffic or working at your job or paying
your rent you will be like homeless and
hungry and alone this is not to worry
you or anything I'm just telling you how
it feels for a lot of people I will say
that adulthood gets much much better
speaking of which last night my son cute
on my face like not on my shirt or on my
shoulder or something but on my actual
like sensory organs babies do this all
the time they're like little puke
factories to put this in context even
though a baby threw up on my face last
night and I slept for like two hours I
would still rank last night as better
than almost every night of the first two
years after I graduated from college so
it does get better I promise but I know
the crushing monotony and paralyzing
terror can be a little bit overwhelming
plus is like a 20 percent chance that
you're unemployed and like a 100 percent
chance that you're underemployed like
unless you're in a successful Time Lord
rock band you're probably not doing what
you want to do every day how are you
going to solve these problems two ways
number one time these things take time
number two you're gonna get an Eileen so
for a few months after I graduated from
college I worked as a student chaplain
at a Children's Hospital that I bumped
around a little until I got a job at
Booklist magazine where 90% of my job
was typing ten digit codes into a
database kind of crushing the not need
to be honest with you but I was
surrounded by books and I had these
amazing co-workers most of whom were
much older than I was and they owe me to
do all kinds of grown-up things like
opening a checking account and not
crying so much when I would get dumped
which was frequently but one of these
colleagues at Bill Coast was a woman
named Eileen Cooper who's a writer I
mean is published more than 20 books for
children from a picture book about the
Golden Rule to a biography of JFK to a
new novel called angel in my pocket
just absolutely delicious one day I went
into her office and I said I would like
to take you out to lunch because I am
also a writer and there is this book
that I would like to write and it's
gonna be real good she said okay we went
to the Cheesecake Factory and I was like
I have an idea for a book it's set at a
boarding school and in the middle this
thing happens and then at the end
there's an ending and Eileen said that
sounds great finally early in 2002 I
brought Eileen 40 single spaced pages
and for the next two years she worked
with me to turn those 40 single spaced
pages into a novel that would eventually
become Looking for Alaska
the only reason Looking for Alaska
exists the only reason I have a job
writing books the only reason there's
Brotherhood 2.0 or nerdfighteria is
Eileen whoever you are to get through
the period of crushing monotony and
paralyzing terror you need an Eileen and
it can't be me because for one thing I'm
already trying to be an Eileen for a
bunch of people like ransom Riggs author
of miss Peregrine's Home for peculiar
children I was kind of a little bit of
an Eileen for him not as much of an
Eileen as Eileen is but a little so
that's my advice for navigating the
treacherous waters of life after school
find someone who's doing something you
want to do better than you can do it and
listen to them and you should really
check out Eileen's book angel in my
pocket for the middle grade reader in
your life there is a link in the
doobly-doo it's great not the link the
book the link is just a regular link
I've signed 42,000 copies of your books
and I'm going to continue but first I
have to go to the doctor because my hand
isn't working right and I've got to get
occupational therapy I wish I were
making that up Hank I will see you on
Friday